[Music]
how hi Kelly
thanks for introducing me to your good
neighbor campaign my name is David
DeLoach I'm a musician and I recently
started playing my guitar and my lap
steel out on the sidewalk in front of my
mom's retirement facility that is on
lockdown I've been playing for her and
her fellow residents that could come out
on these balconies and hear me play we
get to interact with each other but I'm
a good safe distance away 30 or 40 feet
away but it's a wonderful opportunity to
connect with these people help them help
brighten their day since they're in
lockdown getting cabin fever I'm sure
[Music]
this is the kind of music I'd love to do
I've been playing for the elderly when I
can for a few years I play for the
homeless downtown Nashville a volunteer
for a great organization called guitars
for vets down at the VA teaching guitar
to veterans who are overcoming PTSD it's
been the best thing I've ever done with
a guitar in my hands
for those of you watching let's keep
this going join the campaign so we can
be good neighbors together
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going